we're all deeply obsessed with our folks
right everyone is constantly staring at
this thing I remember a time back in the
day where you didn't have a phone and if
you were standing on a corner waiting
for a friend you would just have to
stare into space or make some original
thoughts in your head or something like
that we no longer have any of that we're
always looking at this stuff we're
always connected but these tech kids
they came up with something interesting
to get us off our phone let's take a
look designed to be used as little as
possible it's the size of a credit card
it only makes phone calls works with
your existing phone allowing you to
comfortably disconnect you can go out
with the Lite phone free of distractions
you'll never miss a call from all right
so the light phone is currently a
Kickstarter we've got a link right down
below and here's a quote from the
co-creator of the light phone we started
building this because it became very
clear that true happiness means being
present so much of our days are spent
connected and staring at screens that we
are losing that presence in so many
situations we built the light phone as a
way for people to find balance with
their connectedness it's not that we
think people should never connect again
it's just that taking a break is
extremely healthy in every sense of the
word so I could not agree with that more
and now I get all do irony in that I'm
doing this on YouTube you're probably
watching on your phone or your iPad I
tweet all the time tumblr yeah yeah it's
all very exciting anyway we're
constantly doing this stuff and we've
got a bunch of stories on this on the
show and I really am a firm believer
that we are actually losing something
because I see this all the time like
I'll have you know some friends over for
dinner and I try to make a point of not
bringing my phone out I think when you
do that when one person does it then
everyone starts not doing it right and
then you can actually have like a
two-hour conversation without everyone
doing this the whole time I'm looking
down but I always notice that the second
one person takes it out it's like
everyone got suddenly the license to
take out their phone and start staring
down and it's like we're all humans
right we're all humans sitting in a room
together and we're all doing this to try
to connect with somebody that were
were thousands of miles away from or
something and I do think it's changing
the way we interact we've there's been
plenty of scientific studies about how
it's actually rewiring our brains and
changing our attention spans there's all
kinds of stories about people that are
addicted to the Internet so this idea of
just having a phone let's not forget by
the way that cell phones I got my first
cell phone I think in 2001 so that's not
even 15 years ago and that and basically
all it was was a phone at the time was
one of those little Motorola things I've
had I could play snake that's pretty
much all I did and you know we went from
that to walking around with this thing
that is literally like part of us not
literally but it feels like it's part of
us and I really do think it's changing
so the idea that you could just walk
around with a phone that you on a day
you go to the beach leave the smart
phone in the car and you know there's an
emergency you got to talk to mom you can
actually make a call so you have that
and that only sets us back 15 years I
know it seals like it sets us back you
know eternally right like we're going
back to 1920 but I don't think it's
quite the quite the idea here anyway I'm
going to I'm going to get one of these
things and see what happens when it
comes out I'm curious what you guys
think let me know in the comments right
now